salut alors comment allez vous en cette
belle journée de printemps est bien en
ce qui me concerne sachez que je suis
pas au bon endroit par aman donc bonjour
à tous vous ne me connaissez pas alors
laissez-moi me présenter je suis plaitis
je suis un vidéaste spécialisée dans
pokémon et plus particulièrement dans la
chasse aux chats ni cependant je ne
chasse pas pour moi mais pour les autres
mon concept est super simple je chasse
un pokémon au pif et je le fais gagner à
quelqu'un à l'aide d'un mini jeu lui
aussi tiré au sort d'où ma présence
aujourd'hui parce que oui j'ai pas pop
et de façon aléatoire
aujourd'hui pour la vidéo centrée sur la
quatrième génération
vous aurez l'occasion de remporter un
magnifique rieux louche annick bas
attendez vous le montre voilà donc il
est beau donc ce petit gars a été
chassée oppoca radar sur pokémon xy et
si vous voulez tenter de le remporter
c'est super simple vous avez juste à
retrouver un mot bien précis dans cette
vidéo
toutes les lettres de ce mot ont été
séparés et dispatcher à travers toute la
vidéo dargaud rock
à vous de le reconstituer bon allez je
vous laisse avec argo rock justement il
saura vous expliquer plus en détail son
jeu moi je vous dis bonne vidéo
bonne chasse au trésor et surtout bon
appétit très important la fuite
[Musique]
effectivement un mot de six lettres est
caché dans la vidéo il vous faudra
retrouver chaque lettre pour former le
mot le premier a retrouvé le mot complet
et à le mettre dans les commentaires
sera le gagnant du riolo chailly je
tiens à remercier mon ami plated de
participer à la vidéo est d'avoir chassé
sur you look rien que pour vous cette
personne a le pokédex nationale en shiny
soit les cette génération de pokémon
complète
je vous conseille donc d'aller voir sa
chaîne c'est la chasse de pokémon
szczesny vous intéresse pour ma part
c'est mon cas et sa chaîne est un réel
plaisir à regarder
surtout que ce mini jeu vient de plenty
ben car oui ce char youtuber fait gagner
des chats ni grâce à des mini jeux comme
celui-ci organisé aujourd'hui
bref passons à la vidéo
[Musique]
et bien cela faisait longtemps oui j'ai
envie aujourd'hui de vous parler de
pokémon passionné depuis mon plus jeune
âge c'est certainement la licence auquel
j'ai le plus joué
mais si vous ne le saviez pas quand
j'étais enfant j'ai commencé avec
pokémon diamant et perle
alors oui je sais j'ai commencé pokémon
tardivement mais cela ne m'a pas empêché
de faire toutes les versions par la
suite
bref je ne vous dis pas ça par hasard
car j'aimerais aujourd'hui tourner mon
trois théories autour de la quatrième
génération justement et voici donc les
théories que je vous propose
je pense que vous avez déjà deviné le
but de cette théorie effectivement dans
pokémon en ruby oméga et saphir alpha il
eu l'arrivée des primes aux résurgences
respectivement associés à kyogre et
groudon par le biais de la gemme rouge
et bleu la prime aux résurgences permet
à ces derniers d'acquérir des pouvoirs
antique qui vont décupler la puissance
de ses légendaires
cependant j'ai envie de vous dire qu'au
gré good on ne sont pas les plus vieux
légendaire et oui dans les origines de
pokémon arseus est apparu et a donné
naissance au célèbre trio de dialga
palkia et giratina dialga et encore plus
vieux que kyogre et godon venons en au
fait pourquoi dialga n'aurait-il pas une
prime aux résurgences si vous êtes un
réel jour de pokémon vous avez forcément
jouer à pokémon donjon mystère
explorateurs du temps de l'ombre ou bien
du ciel ce sont des jeux tout simplement
incroyable avec un scénario digne des
plus grands final fantasy c'est un jeu à
faire au moins une fois dans sa vie
rien que pour le scénario bref si vous
avez joué au jeu vous connaissez
forcément dialga primal le boss final de
ces jeux
la forme primal de ce dernier transforme
diaby en une bête primitive et sauvage
il est même beaucoup plus fort sous
cette forme il n'y a qu'à leurs oeufs
combattre dans le jeu pour le voir c'est
une forme qui est né à cause du
dérèglement du temps et donc de
l'effondrement de la tour du temps où
dialga en est le gardien
la colère et la rage sont les maîtres
mots de cette forme dialga n'arrive plus
à avoir le contrôle
que pouvons-nous argumenté déjà forme
primal veut bien dire primitive
tout comme primo de primes aux
résurgences c'est une étymologie
importante ensuite dialga n'est plus du
tout comme avant il a changé
physiquement
alors bien évidemment sa forme ne change
pas des masses car la prime aux
résurgences n'existait pas encore à
l'époque de pokémon donjon mystère mais
la charte graphique de dialga n'est plus
la même
les 101 bleus beaucoup plus sombre
accompagnée d'un rouge agressif cela
confirme bien que dialga aurait changé
de forme comme lors d'une prime aux
résurgences saga primal possède bien une
force antique
tout comme la prime aux résurgences de
kyogre et goudon si vous n'êtes pas
convaincu j'ai envie de vous rappeler
que diaga primal est très dangereux pour
le monde et est une réelle menace pour
ce dernier
exactement comme la prime aux
résurgences de kyogre et groupe dont où
l'un peut inonder le monde et l'autre à
sécher ce dernier se sont aussi de
réelles menaces sous cette forme
néanmoins dialga prime allait seulement
animée par la colère de ce dernier
contrairement à primo kyogre et gros don
qui nécessite seulement la possession
d'un objet pour l'échangé c'est me dire
qu'il faut utiliser les rouages du temps
pour changer dialga mais les rouages du
temps sont plutôt ici vous rendre
l'apparence normal de dial cas quel gars
primal devient seulement de plus en plus
sombre au fil du jeu alors que la prime
aux résurgences et l'instantané est ce
que nintendo avait déjà prévu la prime
aux résurgences depuis des années ou
bien est-ce que diaga primal est
seulement un dark dialga j'ai envie d'y
croire mais à vous de me le dire dans
les commentaires
[Musique]
à
je suis un fan de la quatrième
génération en même temps j'ai commencé
avec celle ci est l'idée qu'un remake de
ces derniers puissent apparaître me
faire réellement vie la septième
génération une nouveauté est apparue et
ce sont les ultra super ce sont deux
mystérieux pokémon surpuissant est très
dangereux provenant d'une dimension
parallèle que l'on peut accéder par le
biais d'une ultra brèche ces pokémon
viennent d'une autre dimension
je ne vous dis pas ça par hasard tout
d'abord un remake de la quatrième
génération est très convoité par
beaucoup de joueurs et pourrait faire
suite à pokémon soleil et lune
dans tous les cas et sortiront après ses
jeux donc la présence d'ultra chimères
serait obligé dans l'histoire de pokémon
arcis est apparu et a créé dialga palkia
et giratina pour créer le monde dialga
contrôler le temps palkia l'espace et
giratina est le mâle créé par ces us car
le bien engendre le mal forcément il fut
donc banni dans le monde distorsion
cependant on dialga palkia giratina ne
vivent pas dans le monde des pokémon
chacun vit dans une autre dimension
parallèle nous connaissons le monde de
giratina le monde distorsion
là bas il est d'ailleurs sous sa forme
originelle
ce qui prouve bien qu'il ne vient pas de
notre monde et bien c'est pareil pour
dialga et palkia ils vivent chacun dans
leur propre dimension
regardons pokémon ruby oméga et saphir
alpha qui voulait attraper dialga palkia
giratina vous devez passer dans une
brèche spatio temporelle pour les
attraper ceci est typique ultra chimère
personnellement cela me fait réellement
pensé à eux
il serait d'ailleurs tous les trois les
ancêtres des ultras chimères avec arseus
aux commandes palka contrôler l'espace
dialga le temps et tout comme giratina
les ultras chimères sont plus forts dans
leur dimension et dans cette dimension
le temps s'écoule et l'espace fut créé
forcément par dialga et pas le cas
ailleurs pokémon soleil et lune ont un
lien avec la quatrième génération
je ne vous l'apprends plus type 0 est un
mini arseus qui est d'ailleurs créée
pour combattre les ultras chimère car
c'est une [ __ ] à part on va dire de
ces derniers le seul ayant le dessus sur
ces pokémon alors oui je me contredis
pour dialga avec ma première théorie sur
des algues a pris mal mais sachez que si
un remake de la quatrième génération
tout comme ruby oméga avec la prime aux
résurgences et pokémon soleil et lune
avec les ultras chimère une nouveauté
apparaîtra en rapport avec les
légendaires de cette version prime aux
résurgences ultra chimères méga
évolution ou tout simplement autre chose
au final je pencherais plutôt pour le
dernier cas de figure nous parlons des
créateurs du monde après tout
[Musique]
bon cette théorie est beaucoup moins
historique épique car nous n'allons pas
parler de légendaires mais elle reste
tout de même très très intéressante
luttons et l'un des commandants de la
team galaxie apparu dans pokémon platine
et c'est un savant de génie il faut le
savoir
outre son plan machiavélique pour
utiliser la puissance 10 tran grâce à la
pierre magma pour extorquer des millions
d'habitants pluton est à l'origine de la
découverte des formes de mode isma donc
tous les stratèges utilisant motisma
machine à laver en combat vous pouvez
remercier pluton réellement bref ceci
nous montre bien que ce savant fou n'est
pas quelqu'un d' idiot j'irai même plus
loin en disant que c'est un génie
les formes de motis ma sont arrivés lors
de la quatrième génération là où pluton
est apparu lui aussi mais un autre
pokémon est aussi apparu lors de ces
jeux c'est pour rigoler aide
ce dernier est donc forcément créé
durant cette période j'ai une
explication à vous partager
il est dit dans le pokédex qu'on a
modifié son programme pour qu'il puisse
parcourir la dimension
mais ce fut un échec ou bien qu'un
nouveau logiciel était censé lui
permettre de voyager entre les
dimensions
mais tout ne se passe pas comme prévu et
il y a eu des bugs pourrait concept est
un pokémon créé lors de pokémon platine
diamant et perle et devait servir à
parcourir la dimension
malheureusement ce fut un échec vous
avez compris où je voulais en venir
seul un savant de génie a pu créé ce
pokémon est le seul durant cette période
n'est autre que pluton mais pourquoi
aurait-il fait ceci dialga palkia
giratina vivent dans une autre dimension
je vous rappelle
bourillon z fut créée pour voyager dans
ces dernières et permettent donc à la
team galaxie de les atteindre surtout la
dimension de giratina pour posséder le
monde parfait kelio convoitait mais
comme l'expérience fut un échec
elio changea le plan pour faire venir
directement giratina à lui grâce à son
fils en rouge pour confirmer cette
théorie il faut savoir que l'amélioraton
or permettant de faire évoluer pour igor
vori dont 2 a été créée par la cie la
sarl mais nous ne connaissons pas la
provenance du cddp te permettant
d'obtenir port et gong
l'objet apparaît seulement dans la
quatrième génération est disponible sur
la route 225 peut être tombé de la poche
de pluton lors de son ascension du moins
abrupte peut-être et après tout ce ne
sont que des théories et j'ai pris un
malin plaisir à les imaginer à les
façonner à ma façon
et j'espère qu'elle vous auront plus
pokémon est une licence que j'ai torché
depuis mon plus jeune âge et je suis
heureux d'avoir rendu hommage à la
quatrième génération
lou cariot et car chaque rock à jamais
dans mon coeur donc merci à ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo c'était argot rock
et que le line up soit av
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]